Haydn's opposed to to pot really yeah
like people have like gone nuts like
what is he doing
young people want regulated legalized
like well he's taking his time he's
getting one group at a time to not vote
oh we didn't even talk about that yeah
let's talk about it now
all rights move on Joe Biden is back oh
my god Joe Biden is on fire Trump
campaigns like literally burning look at
this the Trump campaign is selling you
ain't black shirts after Biden comment
oh no like me I mean this is a little
much
come on capitalize on your I mean he
said it though that's the crazy thing
that blows me away like what this is the
difference whole idea Joe Biden
apologizes Donald Trump sells the shirt
ha this is this winner look man it's
funny to me that all these conservatives
came out and we're like railing on Biden
like how dare so so let me give you guys
the context first cuz I'm sure most of
you know cuz it was a nationwide trend
yeah all day I got I got offended you
know a little bit from this I'm like wow
so Joe Biden's doing an interview with
what's the Breakfast Club yeah
Charlamagne egad right and what's a
Biden basically says I've got to go my
wife's got to come on and Charlemagne's
like well you know when you come back to
New York I got more questions for you
and then Biden's basically said if you
haven't figured out you know if you're
voting for me you know if you're voting
for me or Trump then you ain't black or
whatever right something like that
and Charlie mean the guy was like no
it's not about white or black it's about
real questions yeah and I was like dude
yes yes yes thank you exactly yeah I
want some for my community so joe biden
man he forced it to be a race issue
wouldn't he threw that out there you
know what's crazy is um when joe biden
is incoherent he's better off yep it's a
good point
think about the things he said when he
was actually making sense think about
all that sentence alone though
that right there he's better off when
he's coherent this man is running for
president and that's where we're at oh
dude I love it it's just like this is
not real life is it I'd rather hear
about the thing the thing that's the
thing he's gone with that I know I know
why he said that though the thing yeah
that wasn't necessary 'king right right
he says go he goes we're created under
go you know the thing guys I think he's
trying to say God he knew to say God but
he was but he realized the last minute
like uh-oh Democrats social justice yes
you can't say the Democrats so he
exactly he was like you you know the
thing and now he has the famous you go
you know the thing yep dude this is the
perfect example of the difference
between the two campaigns Trump hopped
right on and said we're gonna sell you
have pictures of the shirts they don't
buy money though where do they have it
they don't have it okay whatever yeah
they should
well they're not trying to sell this yes
the shirts which cost thirty dollars
were revealed on the Trump campaign site
shop just hours after Biden's smart
Chris's on Friday
anyways didn't know time I have the
Trump straws you wanna grab those real
quick the Trump straws sure you see him
no I don't so they're on the you got him
all right so I got someone sent me these
because I'm like I'm not gonna buy
straws from Trump but so somebody sent
ended up cents some people someone's
using these straws who use them look at
this package was it you yes who is it I
saw you using it I think I did these are
perfect
look at these look at that you see that
so they banned plastic straws and
Trump's campaign these people are
brilliant they are missing those they're
absolutely brilliant Trump made what do
you make like a hundred grand he did oh
wow didn't he also make sharpies
remember yes sharpy gate yes I must miss
Murphy so so there was a hurricane and
he has this this diagram that the the
the Noah was it was it yeah
what does that stand for to the northern
oceanic at land occurs in the yawn oh
okay it shows the path of hurricane
right and there was a sharpie line that
drew a bigger bubble oh yes I remember
that and everybody lost their minds and
their and and they were arguing it was
illegal for him to manipulate I'm like
weeks they were talking this National
Oceanic and Atmospheric so Trump sells
sharpies on his website when he made a
ton of money and now we have Trump
stress so I mentioned something about
like it's a genius move you know the
funny thing about the straws argument is
that all these jurisdictions are banning
them you know it doesn't do anything the
US isn't contributing that plastic
pollution to the gyres or the rest of
the world it's other countries like
China and India right so then the u.s.
changes things we're already doing it
okay fine look I don't care well it's an
example maybe - I guess paper straws
suck these are reusable straws I never
even liked it yeah they're reasonable I
actually I actually did back a project
that is a little tiny pack I mean I have
it upstairs and go grab it but it's a
straw that unfolds it's like oh that's
cool yeah it's great it's a it's a
silicone straw cool it comes with it's
got a little cleaning thing in it - it's
awesome
yeah so you just have it on your
keychain there it is pull it up oh I
cannot believe this no I can't believe
it I can completely no to it oh my gosh
Joe Biden Wow wow that's amazing such a
tone deaf and stupid thing for Biden to
say and you know I feel bad cuz you know
he was joking yeah but it's like he
wasn't joking was he he was oh he
apologized for being a wise guy yeah
yeah that's that's what his apology was
it's not what he said I should know I
shouldn't have been a wise guy it's like
oh so you were you thought it was funny
to joke about that hmm listen listen who
wants to wear this shirt anyway let's
let's be honest I don't think Joe Biden
was trying to be racist and I think it's
really stupid when I agree I agree and
that's what I'm saying the bigger
problem is that he's just tactless and
he's so out of touch he didn't realize
that this is not going to like unit it
is he comes from a bygone era yeah
exactly and he's trying to be hip and
with-it
so it's like it's like
watching the old man come out and and
like come on the lawn where the kids are
skateboarding like huh with it I can do
the Lindy Hop you're like I was thinking
I'm like watts we're gonna see him
playing Tony Hawk pro skater like he's
gonna do a tick-tock whatever the kids I
don't know how did that go oh yeah okay
good okay yeah there was a street she
she set the phone in the mailbox and I
was like what is she doing and then she
was like dancing and eyes like damn talk
that's amazing I saw her walking down
the street and they're doing this weird
like walk like an Egyptian thing uh-huh
and I'm like and I say the first thing I
thought to myself was your old 34 your
old man yeah I'm a man yeah I'm like I'm
like what is she doing and then I'm like
Lydia wish this is weird
I think she's looking at her phone no
yeah you're no thank you
nobody was like she's doing it she's
gonna she's looking at her phone she's
got it set there in the mailbox no no
that was that was that was after she was
walking down the street going like I
didn't see that and I'm like I'm sorry
anything like you needed music there I
didn't understand and then and then
actually the other day we were driving
on the street and down this road over
here I saw like some some like young
dudes probably looked like they were in
the they're teenagers and they were
doing something similar yeah like one
guy was filming and they were doing this
weird thing I'm like is there a thing
going on with tick-tock right now
they're doing like the chicken dancer
I'm all married I keep trying to avoid
big talk you can't listen everybody I'm
34 and I know not to try to pretend you
know I mean that's a I'm not gonna do it
I'm not gonna go will always act my age
walk up to some 15 euros and be like
what up kids I'm cool I used to be soup
now sorry dude I'm a man I'm gonna go
take care of the bills kids would
totally think you're cool look at you
skateboarding yeah that's another thing
and I'm like yeah but you still shred or
yeah come to you soon everyone
what I'm saying is I will absolutely
skate and we can talk skateboarding but
I'm not gonna pretend to understand or
try to accurately tick-tock yeah so so
Joe Biden thinks he's being funny with
these young guys like oh I know it
wasn't even about youth it was about him
thinking he understood the black
community and and that he could speak in
a way that would make them laugh yeah
and it didn't it just made progressives
and conservative members of the black
community angry yeah yeah that's what
was crazy to me because I thought we
were gonna immediately see a bunch of
lefty you know lefty members of the bike
community being like no or I'm sorry I
mean like yo Joe Biden's fine it's fine
it's fine
because we saw some on what US I haven't
seen that a few people like I'm Twitter
it's been like a war all day long yeah
where he's losing and his side is losing
most people are pissed about this I so I
clicked the the trending the hashtag
yeah you know Joe Biden is a racist yeah
and sure enough most of the top posts
were from black people and so I was
looking at some of them like cuz I'm not
gonna pretend like I can speak for them
or know their opinions you know exactly
and I got my opinion if Joe Biden said
something like that to me about my
heritage and stuff I'd be like excuse me
bro like are you gonna actually tell me
what you plan to do as a politician yeah
or are you gonna just in deride me for
like what am I supposed to do yeah
especially when Charlemagne wasn't even
talking about that he was he was like
he's like no I'm talking what I'm
talking about real issues for my
community like what are you talking
about Charlemagne to find it into I
think oh no it's fine it's fine because
they're gonna be look I'm not gonna
pretend I I'm not gonna be offended on
his be I'm Charlie Mimi's not seem
offended yeah yeah I'm not gonna pretend
to be offended you know for somebody
else it's ridiculous right I just think
it's an example of Joe Biden being
completely inept and then Donald Trump
selling these shirts shows they're
geniuses we got we got it we got to talk
about the Lincoln project though yes
okay Joe
oh my gosh yes we do can i how do i pull
that up can you pull up it what's the
website oh here let me go to a year I'm
gonna take this time to smash that like
button everybody and go ahead and share
it if you think that we're worthy of
sharing and even if you don't think
we're worthy of sharing share it anyway
to tell people how unworthy we are yeah
thank you appreciate that I appreciate
you guys did you find it I'm trying to
but are they seriously blocking what is
the link of
project anyway no no this is like a
conservative anti-trump thing okay and
it is one of the most like one of the
best pro Trump ads I have ever seen but
it's anti Trump road trip okay yeah this
is just another example that real Donald
Trump is the worst manager America has
ever seen Don you got conned by your
each IT guy um okay so all right I'm
sure I'm gonna turn that down yeah this
is an ad talking about Brad Parr scale
who I think he's the campaign manager
okay um campaign and Brad is a genius
okay like he's the one who he's probably
the one who did the t-shirts he's
probably like this video is like Brad is
getting rich but don't tell Donald he's
got two condos worth 1 million each he's
he's very own yacht as a bunch of
beautiful women bikini chicks in bikinis
dancing on a boat look at this
he's very own yacht a gorgeous Ferrari
I'm like dude don't hang out this guy
Brad's friend what is this please and so
then it's like private planes
oh my hi otherwise it's what does that
look like then the Lincoln project
they're like meet Brad Parr scale
Trump's campaign manager it's weird he
kind of looks like my uncle dude they
say they know it's random but I watched
this school and I'm lying chol is really
cool so I already like this guy a little
more so I'm watching this and they say
Trump can win without him he's worth
every you know every penny or whatever
you know beautiful men dancing Ferraris
and I'm like this is like one of the
most epic pro-trump ads I've ever seen
every young guy in this country is gonna
be alike I want to work for Donald Trump
yeah and so the their goal with this is
to their target market is Trump himself
they want to like they want to upset
Trump if they want Trump to feel like
they're making Brad look bigger than him
okay like Trump has to feel that they're
trying to make Trump feel inadequate I
guess but that to me that seems like
they've been eating their own refuse
like the fake news about Trump and
everything yeah they keep seeing these
things that they write to do like to
rile each other up and then have this
fake version of Trump in their heads the
were they
think Trump would actually fire a guy he
made rich in the first place now hold on
I saw that I thought to myself I mean as
a possibility Trump could do that true I
don't believe it I don't know bad parse
kales been like promoted and their if
their argument is Trump made this guy
rich why would Trump be mad about that
yeah why wouldn't Trump watches and be
like yeah like all right Brad he learned
proud of you right look what you did
because of me look he'd be like yeah I
did that Trump would probably loves it
look at this that look what Serna [ __ ]
said here's the response if there is one
lesson from 2016
it's that American voters will never
vote for a rich guy who surrounds
himself with beautiful the takeaway here
yes yeah nice job thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you